Taylor Swift is making worlds converge.
She's already generating tons of buzz by attending
Kansas City Chiefs games, but now she's got
Marvel fans speculating about whether she'll
be a movie mutant sometime soon.
Taylor Swift’s relationship with pro football
star Travis Kelce — seemingly a romance
— has sparked interest in the sport among
Swifties.
The pop star has cheered for him at several
Kansas City Chiefs games, but her latest appearance
with some Marvel heavy hitters has fueled
speculation about a possible superhero role
for the "Anti-Hero" singer.
Swift attended the October 1st Chiefs-Jets
game at MetLife Stadium with an entourage
in tow, including bestie Blake Lively; Lively's
husband, Ryan Reynolds; Hugh Jackman; and
director Shawn Levy.
Reynolds and Jackman will share the screen
as Deadpool and Wolverine in the upcoming
"Deadpool 3," with Levy directing.
They could all just be friends hanging out,
but there's also a chance Reynolds could work
some magic and get Swift a part in the threequel
as the X-Men's resident pop star.
That's the theory being spouted by accounts
like MediaVerse: Comics Unwrapped on X, formerly
known as Twitter.
The fan community site posted,
"Okay so seemingly Taylor Swift as Dazzler
in Deadpool 3?"
It's all just a rumor at the moment, but the
pieces could be falling in place for the Swiftie
and Marvel fandoms to unite.
Reynolds has already proven himself to be
adept at getting A-list cameos in his superhero movies.
"Deadpool 2" features blink-and-you'll-miss-it
appearances from Brad Pitt and Matt Damon,
so Taylor Swift in "Deadpool 3" wouldn't be
out of the question, especially considering
how close Swift is with Blake Lively.
Reynolds has fielded questions about Swift's
involvement before.
Although he denied rumors of a Swift cameo
in "Deadpool 3" to Entertainment Tonight in
November 2022, he added that he would certainly
support such an idea.
"Of course.
Are you kidding me?
I would do anything for that woman.
She's a genius."
As we all remember from the media coverage
leading up to 2021's "Spider-Man: No Way Home,"
just because an actor tells a reporter something
isn't happening in an MCU movie does not necessarily
mean that thing isn't happening.
And Swift wouldn't even be the first major
pop star to show up in the quintessential
shared film and TV universe — for better
or worse, her ex Harry Styles memorably cameoed
as the flamboyant cosmic being Eros, aka Starfox,
in 2021's "Eternals."
Reynolds never mentioned any specific character
Swift could play, but she's been fan-casted
as Dazzler, aka Alison Blaire, since all the
way back to her visit to the set of "X-Men:
Apocalypse" in 2016.
In the comics, Dazzler is generally affiliated
with the X-Men and juggles her singing career
with her duties as a superhero with the power
to convert sound into concussive blasts of light.
It's the perfect role for Swift, especially
with how crowded "Deadpool 3" is shaping up to be.
Jennifer Garner will reportedly return as
Elektra in the film, and there are rumors
the likes of Halle Berry and Patrick Stewart
could return to the roles of Storm and Professor X.
And Shawn Levy has hinted that some surprise
cameos could be in store for fans, telling
Entertainment Weekly,
"The rumors of actors, singers, sports stars
who are all apparently in 'Deadpool 3' are fabulous.
If all I read was the internet, I would have
the greatest cast ever assembled in the history
of cinema, so I'll simply say that some of
those rumors are true, and some of them aren't."
Given how successful the cinematic release
of "Taylor Swift: The Eras Tour" is expected
to be, it'd be a good idea from a financial
perspective to get her involved.
As Travis Kelce and the Kansas City Chiefs
are quickly learning, the "Taylor Swift bump"
is very real.
"I think what happened on Sunday makes him
the most famous player in the NFL.
Like that!"